let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
welcome everybody this is the tony
michaels and this is gabe sanchez and we
put together the best of the week from
the tony michaels podcast don't go
anywhere stay right here for the best of
the week
the hungarian autocrat orban invites the
american fascist refuge in his country i
don't know if this is a sign that that
american fascism is obviously not
welcome here i mean they got to hold
their nazi i mean excuse me their manga
rallies their trump rallies and abandon
livestock fields because no one will
have them because they can't pay their
[ __ ] bills so apparently cpac had to
pack up and move to a foreign country i
don't think they're actually exporting
american fascism i think what they're
trying to do is import hungarian style
fascism they love this stuff ah they
[ __ ] love it so much so that the
cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopy pants
himself appears now most people did not
see this until it was actually posted on
a real social media app on twitter no no
one saw it on true social it's all
[ __ ] bot accounts over there they're
all [ __ ] fake either that or they're
just trump sycophants either way trust
me i know i opened up a [ __ ] account
on true social i'm on two social and the
minute i posted a video like it didn't
even go it didn't even have a chance for
the algorithm to pick it up they
censored it that's right true social
censored my freedom of speech so grandpa
poopypants posted on tooth central which
he calls it that he wants civil war
that's what it appears and of course
this is not surprising that a dictator
wannabe like the cheeto dust mobster
would post a read post or whatever the
[ __ ] it's called over there re-shit i
guess you re-shit it over there i don't
know you [ __ ] out stuff on true social
you re-shit it [ __ ] i don't know i
haven't quite figured out the platform
yet it's a complete copy of or it's a
it's like if you went down to the
half-assed dollar store and you and they
ordered a wish.com twitter and it came
in a really broken [ __ ] package
that's that's what that's what two
central is
but on truth social the former dictator
wannabe he he rebreathe [ __ ] something
that's that indicates that there may be
a civil war which is not surprising
again that that [ __ ] fascist would
call for civil war that's what he was
calling for in december of 2020 after he
lost the election got his [ __ ] ass
stopped by joe biden the american people
said no [ __ ] you don't get to be our
fascist dictator no [ __ ] go back to
mar-a-lago you [ __ ] snowflake and he
just wouldn't he wouldn't just do what
most decent human beings do because he
is not a decent human being most
reasonable people retire from the
presidency with dignity nope not a
[ __ ] ounce of dignity or decency in
that [ __ ] he continues the
scourge of how he won the election the
big lie you remember he called on all
the proud boys and the oath keepers
which they're in the news and they will
continue to be in the news for a long
period of time here especially over the
summer but he called on the prowl boys
and the oath keepers to come save him
the moglodites the trump humpers the
maga fascist dark manga he called on
them to come to washington dc to save
his ass and boy did they try oh did they
try on january 6 to make sure that mike
pence did not certify our vote which is
all ceremonial in the first place we
know this and i think frankly we're
going to hear a lot more about this
coming up in the month of june as these
select committees become public and this
testimony becomes public we are going to
get to see the story of what actually
happened on january 6 but we know a lot
they tried a civil war they tried a
cheeto dust kangaroo coup we have people
in this country who are sitting in
detention as we speak for a conspiracy
to commit sedition against the united
states of america people who are not too
far steps away from the cheeto dust
mobster himself and we have more and
more and more people we had confirmed
this weekend that the oath keepers are
cooperating with the federal prosecution
of the seditious conspiracy where
stewart rhodes the founder of the oath
keepers was in charge of a qrf a stash
of weapons where his lieutenants joshua
james and brian ulrich were in command
of that qrf and joshua james protecting
roger stone and brian ulrich admitting
in open court when he took his plea deal
that yes he was trying to make sure that
joe biden would not become president
that there was not a peaceful transfer
of power is the words used in open court
there is a civil war going on now
whether you want to believe it or not
there is a coup attempt still in motion
it's still going they're trying to take
over the secretary's estate because
frankly the coup didn't work last time
more like a black practice want run if
you want to call it that testing it out
testing out the waters find out where
the rough patches are that way you can
avoid those rough patches the next time
well guess what every time is the next
time now with these [ __ ] fascists
every single [ __ ] time is the
next time tomorrow we have the primaries
down in texas it is time right now is
the time to show these fascists who we
are and how we're not gonna put up with
their [ __ ] their hungarian style
[ __ ] not gonna do it go to the
ballot you vote vote vote vote your
friends your family your community
members your church members it is so
important for them to know that we are
pro-democracy here we are not for
autocracy and there's only one
pro-democracy party in this country
right now unfortunately i wish there was
more but there's not there's only one
party that is interested in protecting
your liberty and protecting your rights
only one jesus christ they're
outsourcing their fascism their style of
fascism to try to take your [ __ ]
liberty the civil war is ongoing it will
continue folks and it's gonna continue
past trump the only reason why he's
calling for civil war now or it seems to
be that he's calling for civil war is
because he's [ __ ] terrified he's
painted himself into a corner just like
he did in 2020 when he [ __ ] lost he
seen the walls closing in he wasn't
gonna have the protections of the
presidency anymore he couldn't fend off
investigations and prosecutions and
indictments hell his way of life to
launder money may be in jeopardy so what
did he do he committed civil war on our
country he attempted a cheeto dust
kangaroo coup on january 6 their plan
was not to transfer power peacefully
jesus christ they had a gallows out
front to hang his vice president if his
vice president didn't do what the [ __ ]
he said and they chanted hang mike pence
hang mike pence hang mike pence you
don't think you don't think that's call
for civil war you don't think these
[ __ ] trumped-up white militiamen that
were in flak jackets they were ready to
go to battle at the capitol for what
they seen as their orange mussolini
jesus you don't think that is an image
of civil war you don't think you don't
see it as un-american you don't see it
as unpatriotic that they wanted to rip
up the constitution and wipe their asses
with it and declare donald trump the
king because they just can't handle
losing [ __ ] bunch of snowflake
[ __ ] is what they are scared
terrified and we could have them on the
run folks we already know that there's 8
million more of us than there are of
them already we know that bare minimum
we know there's 8 million more of us
than there are of them and if you don't
think after that after that vote in 2020
that more of those people are on the
side of pro-democracy well i think
you're fooling yourself but don't get
complacent this is not the time to stand
back and want fascism take control nor
the congress nor the senate nor the
governorships the secretary of state's
the attorney general's jesus christ all
the way down to dog catcher if they have
a whiff just a [ __ ] stench of trump
vote them out it's time right now today
is the time to beat back fascism
speaking of uh the people that remind
you of neural civilis you posted this um
what what i'm trying to get my
transitions yeah you're good the
transitions baby the transitions the
transitions are badass here on the tony
michael's podcast you will not find a
transition that is better doesn't this
guy remind you of like a neurosyphilis
in human form though i mean oh like if
neurosyphilis became a human form it
basically might be in if it just again
morphed into a body into an animate
object it was like boom greg this is
this is neural civilization some of
y'all been reading the newspaper do you
think we're crazy nobody's forcing you
to be here today
drag him out right now in jesus name
drag both of them out in jesus name get
out in jesus name you demon you do it
while i'm preaching i'll take this
microphone and bust you to mouth with
the name of god cause we ain't playing
your stupid democrat games and so father
we need to be released in a spirit of
giving we might need to give a little
bit so we can increase security around
here and lord it ain't gonna get no
better it's gonna get worse people to
make up our mind who side their own in
this fight saying that i called last
week to take up arms against the
government if they heard that it's
because they're smoking crack or
apparently they didn't pay attention you
god hating communism you'll find out
what an insurrection is cause we ain't
playing your garbage we ain't playing
your mess so that wasn't at all what i
said they don't care what you say they
only care what it sounds like you say so
that they can make you say what they
want you to say so they can inviscerate
you and the bible says that we'll take
it by force everybody mad because i said
that in this day and age you can't be a
christian and vote democrat which by the
way you can't okay so i still believe
that because everybody's like oh what we
need to do is take away their tax exempt
stash i got an attorney and i dissolved
our stinking
501c3 in this church because the
government ain't going to tell me what i
can and what i can't say so
irs we don't need your stupid tax exempt
status i renounce
501c3 communism in this church
and the irs and the fbi and everybody
we've been turned into can eat my dirty
socks on live tv
i'm sick of all these limp-wristed false
prophet pastors
siding with the democrats no wonder
these penny-wearing pastors closed their
church down during coven a bunch of
sissies let their wife run the show i
revoke our 501c3 status and our arrest
we don't give two flips what you think
about it we gonna take away his 501. no
yay we gave it up it's stupid so you and
all your compromising communism
501c3 can get out when tyranny becomes
law rebellion becomes biblical i'm
calling for christians to stop being
wimps is what i'm calling for it's
amazing what i'm preaching on today by
the way beware of false prophets which
come to you in sheep's clothing but
inwardly they're ravening wolves i i was
getting this clip confused with another
one that came out i think tennessee
tennessee holler had the other one that
i was thinking of yeah talking about the
irs because that was that was the
popular one oh yeah he's basically
saying we are political organizations we
are not we are not charitable
organizations right exactly he's making
the case right for why they should not
have this tax-exempt status right and
they're all pissed off because they're
like listen i need another g5 on the
runway
so i can just fly it in unison with my
other one you know will you shut the
[ __ ] up for a minute quit saying the
quiet part out loud drag him out right
now in jesus name drag both of them drag
him out in jesus name
hey can you kill that guy but in jesus
name this is why greg locke is losing
his mind this is why people like kenneth
copeland and these other pastors are
abandoning this fool because as as much
as he projects that he knows the
skeletons in their closets what he's
saying in that last clip we were
watching they know the skeletons in his
closet oh yeah they know the skeleton oh
it's a two-way street that's right
and this whole i use god my god is my
excuse to do all my sins like this is
this is [ __ ] ridiculous this is total
full-on projection and you're gonna see
it with the irs thing here what we need
to do is take away their tax exempt
he's saying what everyone is thinking
here even even like kenneth copeland and
all his other pastor buddies they're
thinking the same thing like yeah strip
this guy of his 501c3 and concentrate
and focus on greg locke don't focus over
here and definitely focus on greg locke
now he understands that even if he
doesn't have a tax-exempt status he
still has to deal with um uh what's that
agency that um the irs the irs like we
don't give a [ __ ] if you're exempt or
not right we just need to know if you
are and if we need to collect taxes from
your dumb ass the other thing that he
says is that 501 c3s are communism so
basically what greg locke is saying is
all the 501c3 he's been doing all these
years
all that's been communism
a lot of projections yeah this whole
thing is wild i watched this uh sermon
from sunday you watched the whole thing
no i didn't watch it oh okay like holy
[ __ ] into about an hour because like the
first hour they're playing music and
doing all those stuff and he kind of oh
sorry they're actually doing the god
thing it's like yeah yeah it's like a
couple before greg goes out on his
tangent right exactly and it's not just
he doesn't just go after uh kenneth
copeland in the situation he goes after
other people as well just kenneth
copeland is the like primary target that
is in his island
he's like i got a target on ken copeland
whether it's out of envy jealousy or he
actually does believe kenneth copeland
is a demon and
oakland is a demon i will agree yeah i
agree with gregor listen last week uh i
believe it was we played a yeah a video
of greg locke talking about how he was
gonna you know take the government by
force and democrats or demons and
democrats can't be christians and all
this nonsense on and on and on it went
now apparently over the weekend uh some
tick tockers got a hold of this and they
decided to mass report greg locke to the
irs about his 501c3 i i'm gonna go on a
limb here i don't think he actually
dissolved his 5013c well i mean if
you're saying that greg lock is a liar
then i would definitely agree everyone's
like oh my god he's not exempt anymore
and i'm gonna say [ __ ] i don't know
if he dissolved it he had they were like
you're not one anymore or he's in the
process of doing it but but either way
we're gonna we're gonna look at this
video because i find it very interesting
a couple different things about griglock
because if you go out on the interwebs
youtube especially and you go to some of
these right-wing pastors who are uh
anti-lgbtq they they they [ __ ] say
some hateful ass [ __ ] i mean just
hateful bigoted [ __ ] they do but they're
christians black but they do not like
great glock they have turned on greg
yeah yeah because greg locke puts them
at risk here with some of the [ __ ] he
says
because he really does borderline on
threats he really does uh put a 501 c 3
in jeopardy and that's their entire
existence right like their entire
existence to spread their hatred and
bigotry is to do it tax-free right yeah
we do it tax-free we don't get taxed now
greg lock in this video you're going to
see how he denounces a 501c3 which is
kind of funny and i'll tell you why but
you tweeted jesus i think it's safe to
say manga hate preacher greg locke does
not like televangelist grifter kenneth
copeland which if anyone knows kenny
copeland out there you know he's a woo
he's a wack dude he's the one that was
member of uh covet he was
what what was the video you gotta pick
yeah yeah i'll find the video i know
where he blows like spitting blowing it
away or some [ __ ] some weird ass [ __ ]
like stop spitting on me you kobe
spreader in this video that we're gonna
watch of greg locke here which is uh
i think a couple minutes long kenneth
copeland is a demon and he knows it is
what greg locke said so let's i'm
telling you there are more demons in
evangelical pulpits
than there are hookers in the red light
district of l.a right now they
everywhere
we don't have a red light district here
in l.a i just want to preface that for
people we do not have one that i know of
at least see this is this is the [ __ ]
they do this is projection greg lock has
definitely 100
ordered had sex with and probably done
some
really really gross [ __ ] to prostitutes
sex work is work people we should not
demonize these people we should not make
these people unsafe and griglock is
making the these people who do this job
very unsafe and i'm sure he has done
some vile [ __ ] to people who are in that
field of work and greg locke definitely
has been in the quote unquote red light
district wherever the [ __ ] he thinks
that yeah yeah and he has ordered
prostitutes and had sex with prostitutes
this is projection and nobody wants to
expose them and i get people they'll
fight me i can't believe you named that
name i can't believe you still gullible
enough to follow that fool if i got to
run around with pedophiles if i got to
run around with money grubbing nonsense
i ain't messing with him um more
projection yeah i mean what the [ __ ]
does this have to do with preaching a
sermon from the bible i don't know he
went on a comp he went on a tangent
because the the the sermon it was given
it was like do not follow false prophets
and then he went to this whole thing
about he's like listen i'm gonna say
some stuff that you don't like and i'm
okay with losing friends but what i will
tell you kenneth copeland is a grifter
he's a demon he's a dead he's a false
private he goes he is a grifter he is an
idiot yeah yeah yeah well he doesn't
actually say grifter in here i just said
grifter because that's what he is right
well he calls him false prophet he calls
him a demon and then he goes into the
whole masonic demonic cult thing it's a
whole it's it's
so so so you cut this down right yeah
you went in and you you cut this clip
down to what what we have here yeah this
is like how long was this diatribe that
he uh i want to say that the actual
rant he went on was like maybe 15 to 20
minutes so this is the juicy stuff this
is the juicy stuff there's other people
he mentions in there like just like a
couple things where he's like don't be
surprised if you see this person get
arrested and i was like i don't know if
anyone's gonna really know who these
people are so i just focused on kenneth
copeland and boy did he have a lot to
say about kenneth copeland well let's
get to it so i'm gonna hurt some of you
feelings right now i'm gonna hurt a lot
of my friends feelings right now kenneth
copeland is a heretic you hear me
kenneth copeland is the number one
christian heretic in america
he hates him some [ __ ] kenneth
copeland yeah yeah i he [ __ ] he he
has turned on kenneth copeland here my
guess is it's because kenneth copeland
definitely won't uh throw down any kind
of funds to probably maybe maybe they
don't go to the same you know sex orgy
parties i don't i mean you know those
cocaine sex orgies are kind of exclusive
i hear
so you may have to have an invitation
and greg locke has lost his i guess
remember this guy is is doing his sermon
in tennessee right it's in tennessee uh
i don't know usually he's in a circus
tent like well he really yeah he's in a
circus tent and this is the circus folks
that you're watching here literally for
the show baby welcome to the clown
paying none of my bills and i wouldn't
take none of his blood money know-how
false prophets are false prophets quit
sending the money and buying their books
kenneth copeland is a demon and he knows
it i don't care how much money he's got
he's got a lot and he got it off of
naive christians that ought to tie to
their local church and quit sending them
money i'm just letting it settle in on
you for it i know i got some friends
right now they're like
who's committing pastoral suicide uh
it's not just friends that are like that
greg it's not just your friends like
everyone everybody watching this is like
he's he's over here like fanning he's
like sorry i just put out a big ass fart
of pastoral scenes oh my god this this
[ __ ] guy this [ __ ] guy whoosh oh
no i'm not i wouldn't preach for him if
he begged me tomorrow on his knees you
know why kenneth copeland won't sue me
because he knows i got the receipts he's
a false prophet kenny copeland should be
under the jail you would be shocked if
you knew what's going on behind closed
doors in these pastor's offices wait a
second if this guy knows all this stuff
isn't he culpable into knowing all this
stuff i mean really he says
i don't doubt that there's a lot of [ __ ]
right no for sure for sure i don't know
how he knows if somebody told him he was
the cuck in the corner or he was
watching through a little peephole right
inside of uh inside of a painting you
know like a [ __ ] scooby-doo villain
right but if he knows these things then
he is a witness or he's complicit in a
crime that was committed in these
offices of different pastors what the
[ __ ] does that mean i mean really this
has the stench of cocaine sex orgies
madison
cousins
oh this is right yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
this definitely has cousin humping
written all over and it is you know it
is greg locke and it is kenneth copeland
so you know i don't know if they're
related but maybe that hey i don't know
because the bible says be what a false
prophet so apparently they're around the
only thing they get me on being a false
prophet is i call out democrats and
preach against demons well if that makes
me a false prophet then la da da
da da really honestly this is a circus i
want to see more juggling really
honestly i mean if he brought out clowns
to juggle like bowling pins or something
right i mean yeah
look i would watch every week greg if
you had the clowns come out and do some
juggling and [ __ ] maybe like like the
the fire breathers oh yeah yeah
that might be a little too demonic you
know you know
we got satan's satan's cult up here you
know i don't well well he's going to
talk about satan's cult here in just a
second listen to this i dare kenneth
copeland to take me to court and sue me
for what i'm about to say he is a 33rd
mason why why would kenneth copeland
take him to court because he's a mason
what does that have to do with it that
might be what he's about to say in a
moment oh let's see he is in the masonic
satanic cult
there you go
there you go oh my god what is this [ __ ]
gonna be a spectator at the great white
throne judgment when god looks at
kenneth copeland and says depart from me
ye that work iniquity you going to hell
for all of eternity because you a lion
sorry low down good for nothing sack of
false prophecy we'll wait till we got
all the uh the cards on the table and
we'll just have us a big old national
press conference and we'll just call
them all what they are and now back to
the sermon yeah they say they're
pro-life they say they're american they
say they're patriotic they say save the
children but they stand back and watch
children get slaughtered time after time
after time this will not be the last
time that the gqp has blood on their
hands last week it was a [ __ ] grocery
store and a church yesterday was a
school second third fourth graders
teachers the shooter in yuvali was not a
lone gunman he had the help of governor
abbott the nra senator ted cruz john
cornyn you weak [ __ ] oh i'm
gonna back out of the nra because it
looks bad you know what looks bad you
know what looks really [ __ ] bad john
cornyn you weak piece of [ __ ] dead
children's bodies all over the floor of
a school that's what we should do we
should make the governor and the
senators and all the gqp go mop up those
children off the floor there's a law you
can [ __ ] pass i think the country is
sick and [ __ ] tired of this [ __ ] this
is america folks the land of the armed
and the home of the broken every parent
in the in america this morning was
nervous about sending their children to
a school think about it for a second i
know you hugged your children when they
came home i know you held them as long
as they would let you hold them mental
health mental illness we need mental
health yeah we are going to need a lot
of mental health in this [ __ ] country
can you imagine the mental health care
that the other students the other staff
members the teachers the police officers
the [ __ ] parents of the dead
slaughtered children you pieces a weak
[ __ ] and you're i'm not gonna let you
look away we have voters in this country
that only
only pick out a few [ __ ] issues and
that's what they vote on and every
single time it's to take away your
rights your right to your uterus your
right to your [ __ ] vote and your
right to your children's safety you
don't think we have the [ __ ] right to
live in this country you don't think our
children have the right to learn without
being scared that they're gonna be
[ __ ] mowed down torn apart by a
semi-automatic rifle because you got a
boner for guns so you can protect your
tv and you can shoot politicians you
dirty [ __ ] you dirty
[ __ ] nope i'm not gonna shut up
i'm not gonna stop talking when we're in
a country where a goddamn gun has more
[ __ ] rights than a woman's uterus
it's time it is so it is [ __ ] time if
you're not ready to go to the [ __ ]
polls and vote every single one of these
[ __ ] out you're doing it wrong
this morning i don't care if you're
[ __ ] republican if you're a goddamn
democrat i don't care if you're a
[ __ ] conservative if you're a parent
in this country a [ __ ] grandparent in
this country you should be ready
tomorrow to vote these [ __ ] out
they are gonna go to the [ __ ] nra
conference in texas and cheer cheer the
slaughter children yesterday that's what
they're gonna do and we're just gonna
stand here and let them do it
take our democracy away from us make
this into an autocracy i'm not i'm gonna
keep yelling into this microphone i'm
gonna keep motivating you to stay
[ __ ] pissed it's time to fight with
the ballot enough is enough of this [ __ ]
when will it [ __ ] end when can we
send our kids to school to learn and not
be slaughtered torn apart by a piece of
weaponry that we manufacture in this
country so some [ __ ] dude or some
dumb [ __ ] conservative somewhere can
take a picture of it in front of a
[ __ ] christmas tree you dumb
[ __ ] i've had about a [ __ ]
enough of this stupid [ __ ] where the
minority ideology in this country gets
to tell us what the [ __ ] to do 90 90 9
out of 10 [ __ ] people realize
it's a good idea to do a goddamn
background check before you give someone
a goddamn weapon that is designed to
kill multiple human beings nine out of
ten people already [ __ ] realize it
joe manchin says oh i'll do anything
anything i can do to stop children from
being slaughtered in schools well do
something [ __ ] [ __ ] your career
[ __ ] you being a senator who cares about
your [ __ ] votes stop giving a [ __ ]
about your own goddamn power those
children had no [ __ ] power not a god
damn out of power to stop that gunman
those [ __ ] cops had no power to stop
that gunman good guy with a gun gave me
a [ __ ] break [ __ ] you good guy with a
gun you son of a [ __ ] ken paxton you
[ __ ] so you want you want
[ __ ] teachers you want teachers to be
police officers and the police officers
can't even stop these [ __ ] with
these weapons that's the intent the
intent when they [ __ ] manufacture
this stuff is to make sure that you are
not stopped with the gun
what don't you get how can't we [ __ ]
understand this it's time to vote every
one of those [ __ ] out we need
to be single issue voters in this
country right now not yesterday not
tomorrow not next week right mother
[ __ ] now one issue voters and the
issue is [ __ ] you gqp [ __ ] you that's
our issue that's it right there they're
republican vote them the [ __ ] out they
want your children slaughtered they
don't give a [ __ ] about you they don't
want your rights taken away from you
they don't give a [ __ ] about you you
dumb [ __ ] and until they do
that is our one issue [ __ ] you gqp
[ __ ] you that's your issue go vote go
engage give money don't give thoughts
and prayers
type in five dollars to your local
[ __ ] congressman who can beat that
[ __ ] gqp or who's gonna [ __ ]
have blood on his hands from the nra who
won't [ __ ] stomach stomach even
standing in front of a goddamn
microphone and talking about the
slaughter of children that we can stop
we can stop this we can stop it you can
stop it go vote them the [ __ ] out if
you're not registered go get registered
right now if your [ __ ] family if your
[ __ ] community members are not
registered now is the time right now not
tomorrow now today commit to the one
issue of [ __ ] you gqp that's the issue
one only one you're out of here
[ __ ] you have proven that you
have no intent to govern no intent to
put american people in front of your
power even slaughtered [ __ ] children
mental health get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] you need a [ __ ] head
check you sons of [ __ ] i'm [ __ ]
pissed and i'll stay pissed until these
[ __ ] are gone they don't want
to create policy that prevents children
from being slaughtered well fine we'll
vote them the [ __ ] out we
we can't even we can't even get these
[ __ ] to agree what 90
of people in this country believe that
yes it is really [ __ ] boneheaded to
not do a background check on a piece of
equipment that is designed to kill human
beings multiple human beings what are
you gonna do that's my question what are
you gonna do i'm talking to you the
audience what are you going to do you
got many options you can give money to
campaigns i'll tell you one [ __ ]
option if you're in texas right now i'd
be giving every [ __ ] nickel out of
your goddamn couch every penny out of
your couch to better o'rourke every
[ __ ] nickel greg abbott is the reason
why this happened cheering cheering that
anyone can get a gun anywhere anytime
cheering it tweeting out oh man we
really are in a [ __ ] competition with
other states to have as many guns on the
street as we possibly can have because
that's what makes us safe as you can see
yesterday the evidence is clear more
guns equals dead bodies and that's what
they want i was in junior high when
columbine happened i was about to go
into high school when the national news
was that high schools weren't safe your
classmates could come in and [ __ ]
murder you
and i lived in rural america where every
kid had access to guns every
[ __ ] had access to guns there
was guns in every household in rural
america now they weren't the weapons
that we have today because you gotta
remember in the 1990s there was the
assault weapons ban but we still
wondered when we go to high school are
we gonna have to dodge [ __ ] bullets
are we gonna have to hide on her desk
are we gonna have to run from our
classmates in the cafeteria to save our
[ __ ] lives here we are over 20 years
later and they're still giving us the
same old [ __ ] good guy bad guy [ __ ] guns
don't kill people people kill people
same old [ __ ] same old [ __ ] and these
politicians buy it hook line sinker
because the nra comes to them and says
hey look [ __ ] you don't vote
with us we'll vote you out and we got
the voters look at our register [ __ ]
and they want their power their power is
way more important than 19
19 children being stacked up like
cordwood in texas
their power is way more important than
that duh in the 1990s after columbine
happened the nra wayne lapierre went to
congress and we're in support of
background checks we're supporting
regulation but they soon found out they
soon found out that mass shootings
doesn't equal bad business mass
shootings equals good business they can
really stoke fear inside of their small
percentage their small handful of people
in this country that believe this
garbage and make them go by guns because
they're afraid the government's going to
take them well i'm here to say to all
you gun nuts out there who think you
[ __ ] want the second amendment and
have the second amendment you better get
to the negotiating table [ __ ] fast
quick fast and in the hurry i don't know
how long this is gonna sustain
especially with me yelling and screaming
i'm not gonna stop i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm not going to stop you won't stop me
try to cancel me try to turn me off not
gonna happen i'm gonna yell and scream
at somebody i'm not gonna stop are you
gonna stop it's time to [ __ ] take our
[ __ ] country back it's time to vote
it's time to be one issue voters [ __ ]
you gqp [ __ ] you that's your [ __ ] one
issue they want to reign terror down on
your communities they want to strike
fear into the hearts of your children 19
children went to school yesterday
thinking that they'd ride the bus home
thinking that their parents would pick
them up thinking they were safe there's
even an armed cop at the school to keep
him safe the good guy with the gun there
he is trained with a badge licensed paid
for and because the republicans won't
pluck their heads out of their asses in
this country and realize it doesn't
matter if you have an armed guard at the
school it doesn't [ __ ] matter when
the person comes with better body armor
and a more efficient weapon to kill
human beings doesn't matter if you have
an armed guard it doesn't matter if
teachers have weapons they're just
targets at that point what's next can
paxton you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] you
gonna make sure every child every first
grader every kindergartner every second
grader has a semi-automatic raffle a
rifle slung over their back so they can
protect themselves when someone with the
piece of armory that you won't regulate
comes into a school and tears them to
pieces rips them to shreds with a war
machine huh is that what you want you
want the kids to be armed too i mean
that's the next step ken paxton you
[ __ ] where are you gonna go from
here it's time now is the time it was
time a long time ago columbine sandy
hook parkland [ __ ] last week had a
grocery store in buffalo new york for
crying out [ __ ] loud america pluck
your head out of your [ __ ] ass and
realize that your vote matters your
ballot matters your voice matters it
[ __ ] matters you're the one that goes
to the poll you're the one that talks to
your friends you're the one that says
the things that you need to say to your
community members to motivate them to
make sure these scumbags do not have
their hands on our policy because their
bloody hands are all over it and they're
not going to stop they're not going to
we're going to watch we're going to look
at and watch a lot of really [ __ ]
gross takes on a whole stack of dead
children's bodies this morning and again
maybe that is the solution maybe we
should pass a law to where when there is
a school shooting and there's dead
children that our politicians who make
the policies about keeping those schools
safe have to go mop up mop up the
carnage and clean it up themselves maybe
maybe just maybe their power won't be as
important it's enough of this [ __ ]
america's pissed parents are pissed
teachers are pissed this didn't have to
happen we are doing this to ourselves we
are yes we you must become one issue
voters now right now and it's to vote
out anyone who has an r next to their
goddamn name all the way down to the
[ __ ] dog catcher if they even
have a stench a stench just a whiff of
the nra the republican party trumpism
and maca vote them the [ __ ]
out it's enough of this craziness even
the ones that are like oh well i'm not
i'm not queuing on crazy but that inner
raised up wink love that love that nope
out [ __ ] enough of it and it's up to us
it's up to you i'm talking to you now it
is up to you not just to go vote but you
have to give money to these campaigns if
you can afford it you have to talk to
your community members you have to
organize you have to organize against
these [ __ ] fascists you don't think
that this is fascism they love this they
love this stuff ted cruz is practically
laughing practically laughing when he
blames the shooting that happened
yesterday on democrats as if democrats
haven't tried their damnedest in every
[ __ ] way possible in every legislator
in the entire country to either pass
legislation that would make sure these
weapons do not end up in the hands or
even manufactured and they have either
been stopped by republicans or they
can't stop the legislation that puts
these guns on the street in texas as
long as you have a heartbeat and you're
[ __ ] breathing you get to have a
murder weapon you get to have a machine
of war so you can go into an elementary
school and mow down and murder 19
children why not it's texas pew pew pew
pew i have a lot more faith in texas net
i believe there's a hell of a lot of
people in texas that do not want that to
be texas oh but tony people in texas
they love their guns more than their
children more than their community
members more than the teachers who teach
their children more than the police
officers that have to [ __ ] protect
the school with gunfire are you
listening they had to send a swat team
to a school because greg abbott just was
in a competition of how many guns he can
sell in the state of texas now is the
time right [ __ ] now to show them that
they will not do this to our country and
you can do that by being a one-issue
voter and that issue is [ __ ] you gop
[ __ ] you vote them the [ __ ] out it's
time right now
if you want this to stop if you want to
make sure that a woman's uterus has more
rights than a [ __ ] firearm in this
country if you want to make sure that
your children have the right to go to
school and to be safe to not be scared
that someone's gonna come in and cut
them up with a goddamn weapon of war
that the police officers don't have to
worry about protecting a goddamn
elementary school from warlike gunfire
it's not a school zone anymore it's a
[ __ ] war zone and only we can change
it it's up to us they're not going to do
it you think republicans are going to do
this hell to the no they're not going to
do this republicans are not going to do
this they are not going to change a
goddamn thing not a [ __ ] thing if you
think republicans are going to get off
their asses and do something you just
look at joe manchin who relies on
republicans to vote for him he's like
yeah i'll do anything anything possible
anything in the world that saved
children at schools from being shot by
guns what about the filibuster mr
mansion oh well i can't do that
i mean when i mean anything i mean
nothing and he's a democrat who relies
on republicans to vote for him you think
the republicans who rely on republicans
to vote for them are going to do
something get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] they are not going to do a god
damn thing not a [ __ ] thing not a
[ __ ] thing and i ain't going to put
up with this goal democrats won't do
[ __ ] [ __ ] there's a goddamn bill
right now hr 8 sitting sitting there to
be voted on for background just
background checks just just that that's
not even enough to [ __ ] stop the gun
violence in this country but only just
just that just that [ __ ] thing that
90 percent of the country agree on yeah
you should probably pass a background
check to get a [ __ ] weapon that mows
down dozens of human beings you might
you might want to do that this is what
happens when we have the minority of
ideology controlling parts of our
government and that is up to you and you
may say oh well tony my district is
rigged i'm in a german who gives a [ __ ]
stop with the excuses are you tired of
republicans excuses are you tired of
that [ __ ] good don't have your own don't
have your own excuse now is not the time
to have excuses they're taking away
macbooks they want to marry your
children and they want to have them
slaughtered in schools yesterday is a
sad day in our country and tomorrow will
be too there'll be another one don't
worry it'll be another sad day you'll
shed tears they'll send tots and pairs
they'll talk about how oh it's a tragedy
and mental illness and constitutional
rights and blah blah blah blah
tomorrow will be another sad day because
they won't they're not going to do a
thing they're not going to do a [ __ ]
thing but you can you sure as hell can
you have the power so if you find these
races where you have one of these nra
gun nuts in the race give to their
opponent campaign for their opponent put
a bumper sticker on signed in yard he'll
buy a goddamn flag wave it from your
[ __ ] pickup truck whatever it takes
folks whatever it takes to make sure our
children are safe how is this how is
this such a hard idea anything anything
to keep our [ __ ] children safe just
as real rich that we have to take a
lecture from the people who say save the
children and we can't even we can't even
get these [ __ ] idiots to stop them
from slaughtering our children i want to
talk about how we could have prevented
the horror that played out across the
street
look the killer entered here the same
way the killer entered in santa fe
through a back door an unlocked back
door
i sat down at round tables with the
families from santa fe we talked about
what we need to do to harden schools
including not having unlocked
back doors including not having unlocked
doors to classroom having one door that
goes in and out of the school having
armed police officers at that one door
this is not news of course ted cruz is a
[ __ ] coward and greg abbott and the
rest of the gop with him and again like
i said yesterday that has to be our one
issue folks you are now one issue voters
and that's [ __ ] the gop [ __ ] them that's
your that's your [ __ ] one issue they
want guns to have more rights than the
uterus they want to ban back doors he
wants he wants to ban
back doors that's his solution to
children being slaughtered in schools
ghouls are already [ __ ] locking their
back doors they're creating entire
entrances just because of guns not
because of people the [ __ ] gun it's
the gun you [ __ ] dummy they build
entire entrances on schools to make sure
that a gun doesn't get past a certain
door and ted cruz and they lock the back
doors they lock them [ __ ] they take the
handles off of them at my daughter's
school there are no handles on the
outside of the back doors no handles not
a goddamn handle you couldn't open that
door if you wanted to unless you propped
it open like happens it happens oh if
you just lock back doors children won't
get shot you know after going in and out
of the school that's never happened
before ever in the history of ever ever
ted cruz is a [ __ ] coward and he's
not a dumb [ __ ] i mean i wish i could
call him a dumb [ __ ] and most the time
when he does say some of this [ __ ] it
sounds like he's a dumb [ __ ] but it's
because he's a god damn coward and he
will not stand up for children in texas
he will not stand up for the parents of
those children in texas he will not
stand up for women he won't even stand
up for his own goddamn wife he wouldn't
even stand up for his [ __ ] wife and
we expect this [ __ ] to protect
our children get the [ __ ] out of here
with that backdoor [ __ ] same guy wanted
to ban dildos in texas banned dildos in
women's healthcare and backdoors what in
the actual [ __ ] are you talking about
you coward ass [ __ ] you punk ass
[ __ ] ted cruz and yesterday during the
nra presser because that's what it was
folks where greg abbott and lieutenant
governor dan patrick and the mayor of
uvalde and ted cruz at the nra presser
ted cruz is very nervous very [ __ ]
nervous when beto o'rourke starts
telling them to do their [ __ ] job do
your [ __ ] job [ __ ] you're not here
to protect the gun lobby you're not here
to protect the gun manufacturers you're
here to work for the [ __ ]
people and that mayor of uvalde oh [ __ ]
you talk about vote that [ __ ]
out you don't mean to be doing politics
in this forum it is political
[ __ ] and we're gonna politic
all over your goddamn ass democrats need
to grow some [ __ ] nuts here just like
beto had yesterday it's enough of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] we're like oh well
we can't we can't oh we got a soft hand
we got a light glove [ __ ] that [ __ ] it's
politics [ __ ] we're gonna politic all
up and down this [ __ ] nation all up
and down your [ __ ] asses it's enough
of this [ __ ] i'm tired of hearing about
children in schools people in grocery
stores parishioners and churches
children on the street being killed by
[ __ ] guns it's the gun you dumb
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here
backdoors get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] they're locking the back doors
already cruise you should be so [ __ ]
embarrassed that you should buy a
[ __ ] another plane ticket to cancun
and [ __ ] stay there you piece of
[ __ ] trash the gunless gathering that
they're gonna have this evening in texas
where they're gonna cheer 19 slaughtered
children in uvalde and they're going to
cheer their right their right to make
sure that they can go into schools and
slaughter our children that's their
constitutional right fun fact in the
united states of america we have had a
ban on assault weapons that's a fun fact
isn't it it's happened before you know
what you know you know i it even [ __ ]
worked but forget about things at work
in this country we gotta talk about
things like backdoors mental illness gun
nuts guys with gun boners have to make
sure they have the best weapons of war
to kill our children so we have to pay
good money to train a swat team to wait
for another swat team or stand outside
and guard the school to make sure
parents don't get in while the second
amendment freedom fighter on the inside
mows down and tears apart children with
an assault rifle oh you thought oh well
tony will let up on this he'll let up on
just like oh he'll let up on them taking
the right away from women to the
autonomy of their bodies [ __ ] no i'm not
gonna [ __ ] sugarcoat it either i
don't give a [ __ ] they're [ __ ]
murdering
children yes the politicians in this
country you dumb [ __ ] who are
voting for republicans those politicians
are killing children they're standing
outside of buildings where dozens of
children have been slaughtered talking
about the back door they're gonna go to
a [ __ ] gunless conference think about
this the nra the national rifle
association the [ __ ] organization
that lobbies raises money threatens
these republican politicians to make
sure that there is the right to carry
and kill anyone in this country with an
assault weapon because they have to sell
those weapons to be profitable won't
even [ __ ] allow a firearm inside
their [ __ ] little meeting you know
why they won't allow a firearm inside a
[ __ ] nra convention because they're
afraid of getting [ __ ] gunned down
but they want to give teachers guns i
said the other day [ __ ] the teachers
just give the students guns why not the
gun manufacturers would love to
manufacture a second grade sized [ __ ]
ar-15 they'd [ __ ] love that why not
high-capacity magazines and all
miniature ones of course i mean it would
be great for the christmas card right
lauren bobert you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
talking about how beto somehow is
offensive and oh my god it's the most
egregious thing because he interrupted
the nra presser the other day where greg
abbott and dan patrick were just
repeating what they were told to repeat
by the nra and she's gonna go to a march
for life or some [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
dumbass ron johnson talking about faith
and morals rod johnson's gonna preach to
us the country about faith and morals
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
ron johnson what are you trying to out
ted cruz ted cruz come on give me a
[ __ ] break
faith and morals take your faith in your
morals ron johnson and stick him up your
[ __ ] ass folks we need to make
politics out of this i keep saying all
democrats are going to make politics out
of this that's all it is they're just
politics you god damn right we are why
not what other [ __ ] options do you
have you tried everything else it's been
10 years since sandy hook where a gunman
went in and [ __ ] cut up children
little bitty babies with a gun and the
country pled please begged got on their
[ __ ] knees they put out all kinds of
[ __ ] videos with hollywood elites
saying it not for the soft-handed [ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] we need to
politically punch them in the [ __ ]
mouth it is enough of this [ __ ]
absolutely enough they want to take away
your children's [ __ ] right to learn
by taking away math they want to take
your consent away from your children
especially if that children has
questions about their identity they want
to take your [ __ ] consent away they
want to make sure they have the consent
to marry your children in some states
they want to tell you what the [ __ ] you
can and cannot do with your body your
uterus what decisions you can make with
you and your doctor they want to tell
you what kind of [ __ ] sex you're
gonna have there's some [ __ ] crazy
loon wackadoo i think it's oklahoma it
doesn't really matter where it's at
doesn't matter where these [ __ ] are at
anymore some wackadoo wants to declare
life begins before conception i told you
i [ __ ] told you doubt me i said they
will say that life begins with a boner i
said it i'll go pull the [ __ ] clip
they want to tell you how and who and
when and where you can even [ __ ] they
want to regulate all of it they want gut
big government everywhere besides the
safety of your children besides the
safety of people in a grocery store or
church or a community gathering or
concert a bar a nightclub a restaurant
nah nope gun manufacturers definitely
have the freedom to make sure that they
sell guns and flood the streets with
guns that absolutely [ __ ] tear apart
rip apart americans children fathers
mothers grandmothers black white latino
anywhere in between they don't give a
[ __ ] and they'll pay anything they'll
pay anything for the ability to sell
these weapons on the street hell they're
even promoting to buy these guns for
they won't buy teachers erasers and
pencils but they'll buy him a [ __ ]
handgun
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking